oui effectivement un claude malhuret qui
ici le président du groupe indépendant
est plus qu'un territoire bonjour
monsieur murray on voit à l'assemblée
nationale il a une particularité un il y
a trois députés qui sont également
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
marine le pen jean-luc mélenchon et
nicolas dupont aignan que l'on vient
d'entendre on a pu les suspecté d'avoir
des dépositions qui était comme cela
jugé pro russe qu'est ce que vous pensez
de leur position aujourd'hui quand on
voit cette union nationale du parlement
et des députés qui semble voilà dire
qu'il faut remettre en cause un petit
peu comme cela la position de l'ukraine
notamment sur l'europe écoutez ça fait
des années que ces trois personnes et un
certain nombre d'autres sont les
caniches de poutine n'y a pas d'autre
mot et depuis le début de la guerre les
uns sont devenus les paillassons ce sont
les seuls qui ne condamnent pas
fermement à l'invasion ce sont les seuls
qui essaye de faire en sorte qu' on est
pas l'ukraine qu'on n'en voit pas
d'armes à l'ukraine que l'on ne prenne
pas de sanction ce sont les seuls à
jouer le jeu de poutine encore en
prenant la neutralité de loot ne de
l'ukraine et la situation telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui la la la
l'annexion de la crimée confirmé
l'infection du donbass il continue bien
d'autres bien sûr ils sont obligés de
contaminer l'invasion parce que tout le
monde l'a condamné de condamner les
horreurs et les atrocités mais ils n'ont
pas changé d'un poil ce sont c'était les
caniches de plumes poutine ils en sont
devenus les paillassons et aujourd'hui
ils en sont les complices
[Musique]